But it's a zombie,
what's going to happen to Misaki's body? It hasn't
been that long since she was hit.
It has anti-corrosion and body repair effects,
so there's nothing we can do about it. Her strength is better than before, though, and her senses
may be a little dull.
If the wound is deep, it's a good idea to eat raw meat. Those
close-contact girls seem really cool.
Also, their
saliva must have a strong paralyzing effect. Maybe their
saliva is sweeter than usual. If you
bite into it, you can paralyze the other person for a while.
[Music]
I'm so self-conscious that I think that my kisses should be a reward for all men, and I'm
adamant about excessive women.  I'm going to keep saying that.That's because I'm on the
same level as a man who wants to be my woman as a reward when we meet him for the first time.This
modern society has created something like that.